one yellow chair
thank you I declare this meeting open
good evening and welcome to this Central
area planning committee on Wednesday the
5th of July
2023 my name is counselor John driver
and I am the chair of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
could I ask members to avoid approaching
the top table as this could create
interference with the cameras and live
stream
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask you that when invited to speak
you remember to turn on your microphone
and turn it off again when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise
as possible
um on to item two then
um actually I believe that we've had no
notes regarding or further notes
regarding this beating so uh committee
Clark could I have apologies for absence
please
uh thank you very much so on to gender
item three then minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 19th of April
2023 found on pages seven to ten are
approved as a true and accurate record
and as I wasn't at that meeting is
somebody going to propose Council again
thank you and second
thank you Council Shaughnessy can I have
approval by a sense
thank you very much
on to Declarations of interest uh
item four to disclose the existence
terms hello sorry let me read this out
and then I'll come to you to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests are the
original interests and non-racial
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they are also required to disclose any
such interest as soon as they become
aware should the need arise through the
meeting so Declarations of interest uh
councilor stilts thank you Mr chair I
will declare that I do know the
applicant although he's not close friend
but I do know him
okay thank you against Assurance cancer
Jennings
um thank you chair I also know the
applicant thank you okay thank you
counselor Jennings yes I wish to declare
a non-dis non-registerable interest in
um item number five as I am familiar
with the applicant okay thank you
councilor spensely a non-registerable
interest on item five as the applicant
is known to me and a fellow Trustee of
the modern Festival thank you
okay so oh I'm canceling
similar to councilor Jennings uh
non-registerable interest for item five
the applicant is known to me thank you
okay uh any other declarations no or I
will move on to uh gender item five then
found on pages 11.
to 26.
um
Mr Johnson please could you go through
the reports
thank you chairman
this application proposes a change of
use from class E uh
uh parenthesis e osteopath treatment
rooms to a sewer generous that means it
doesn't fall into any particular
town planning use class
short-term holiday let accommodation
so I'll just run through the slides as
is a customary
so here we have the site here
we've got the High Street there and
we've got White Horse Street to the rear
the application premises is located
towards this end of the premises
again this is just a location plan taken
from the file again we can just see the
site here
specific premises in this area here
again just a block plan hatching
indicating area to be converted at first
floor level
so we can see specifically this is where
the site is
this is a three-story element of which
it occupies the middle floor
and we have the existing first floor
layout as it says here
first floor the subject of the proposed
conversion so this is all this hatched
area
so in the report where it refers to
the previous use of the premises which
is treatment rooms we can see
um
The annotation here of treatment rooms
reception
Etc
and this is the floor space the subject
of the proposed conversion
we have a lounge dining area
kitchen
cupboards
bedroom
so we can then compare the previous
shoes and the and the existing
uh well the the subject proposal
so just some photographs again just
showing the site here
only one single photograph that's all
that needs to be shown
so I'll I'll just leave it there and
I'll just run through a quick summary
of the report
this application proposes a change of
use as I said before from treatment
rooms to a a short-term holiday let
accommodation
the application site is located to the
first floor of the three-story building
front in Whitehorse Lane
previously in lawful use as treatment
rooms associated with an osteopath
Clinic
in essence this is a medical facility
an appeal against refusal of a proposal
for a use of the space
as a one bedroom flat was dismissed
in February this year
and the inspector noted the current
layout was different
from the plans of the one bedroom flat
and what I essentially means is that the
floor space had already been converted
into this
um
the one bedroom flat as was applied
throughout the time and that is
currently the case as things stand and
just as we're background information but
in no way related to this application
here there is just an ongoing
enforcement case running concurrently
because there has been a change of use
but that has no bearing on obviously the
merits of this application in front of
members so just to make that clear
5.2 of the report considers a principle
of the development and at 5.2.2 refers
to policy S5 and at 5.2.3 E5 setting out
the context of support for a range of
uses in the Town Center
policy E3 sets out the support for
Community facilities and the
requirements of a proposal
where there would be a loss of a
community facility
um
and the requirements of a proposal
um that being to demonstrate that the
existing business or service
this is whether the the the the floor
space is occupied by a a running
business or not it's the it's the lawful
use of the premises
um demonstrating that the existing
business stroke service is not and
cannot be made viable
and effective marketing has been carried
out to demonstrate that that is the case
that's the policy requirement
um
and that has to be to the satisfaction
of the council
in the council's view in the officer's
view
um there is no viable and well and for
the the use to demonstrate that there's
no viable and appropriate alternative
Community use
um that can be used in that space so
have they
carry out that exercise to show there's
been no other use that can be used in
this space yeah
there's further elements to that that
assessment which I'll just draw a
reference to
in due course
in this respect the application fails to
provide the necessary supporting
information
to demonstrate the lawful use is not and
cannot be made viable to the
satisfaction of the council
furthermore it is noted the official
pass business has relocated nearby
demonstrating the use itself that type
of use is not unviable
the marketing carried out relates to and
this is the evidence that's been
submitted to the council
to two unspecified periods
one in 2021 and one in 2023
and the advertisement on the applicant's
website States
um and this is in the officer's report a
25 square meter area
and not the 63 square meters of the
application site
in addition there is no evidence that
the rent sort is reasonable normally in
cases like this there would be some
corroboration that the rent is a
reasonable rate for the size of premises
and the use
to you sort
and lastly
no evidence of any commercial aspect of
the proposal
has been submitted
what that effectively means is that the
applicant hasn't stated what this
short-term holiday accommodation would
be in the application
to any significant level of detail for
officers to be satisfied that there is a
viable proposal
um on the table for us to consider
and lastly a number of these points were
noted by the inspector in dismissing the
appeal in February 2023
The Proposal is therefore recommended
for refusal
set out as Section 8 of the officer's
report thank you chairman
foreign
Mr Mr Farley uh your two minutes is up
but I'll just let you finish this
sentence since you couldn't see the
clock
Mr Foley that's that's Mr Foley that's
that's it you've had your two minutes
thank you very much
thank you
okay members I now invite you to put
questions uh or make any comments
regarding this uh report councilor Lagan
uh thank you chair that's um and thank
you very much indeed to the officer for
a very comprehensive and detailed report
um it definitely helps when you're going
through the decision-making process
there's a few comments and um maybe
questions that might come out of it for
Mr Johnson on page number 15 under
5.2.4 it talks about the community
facilities and it says particularly
where they are essential to the local
community
um I know this uh I visited when it was
an osteopathy it's quite small it's not
really a hospital it's not really a
medical facility so I I find that a
little bit um
far for me to say that that is a
Community Asset that could be used for
medical provision
um the osteopaths moved across to expand
their business
um across into into the area of the
courtyard and on that same page under
5.2.5 it talks about the Council of
support developments that positively add
to the growth of the local tourism in a
sustainable manner this is right in the
middle of the High Street
um but it's at the back it's a newer
addition to the old King's Head Center
um and it's it is on the first point on
that page it says where there's an
identified need for the provision
proposed we know we've got an identified
need because we are short on Hotel
accommodation and uh short-term let's
within the High Street
moving on to page 16.
5.2.11 that's that sounds a bit strange
um this is the most recent lawful use of
the premises of medical use which is a
type of community facility I think I've
covered that
um it is a type but it doesn't limit it
to what it should actually be if it was
a designated building that was really 4A
I would say a hospital or some minor
minor injury class I think I would look
at this view this application
differently
um page 17
um on the top paragraph where it talks
about and Mr Johnson's quite right to
talk about it is the REM reasonable if
you break down 5340 quid that's 102
pounds a week for a commercial build and
Brent in a High Street location I would
have thought that is reasonable
obviously there's there's only no test
but looking on the balance of that
um there's just one other thing that
stuck out in my head it's on page 21
it's under
5.7.6 and it says as a result of the
location of the site and the nature of
the development proposed The Proposal of
off-site impacts with nature com
conservation
I've struggled with that a little bit
because it's in the High Street location
um I may be my wider The Mark with what
that actually means but um that is
something that just that stuck out to me
that I'd like to have a little bit more
information upon and I'll leave it there
thank you
uh thank you Council again yes sorry
Castle again just just for clarification
I missed the
um paragraph reference on your last
point
through the chair I was writing at the
same time that's okay uh you have to
balance so many balls when you're up
there don't you so it's on page 17 and
it's the top paragraph
I haven't got the numbers
uh paragraph number is 5.2.11
oh it's in the second half of that
paragraph about the second line up for
the bottom Mr Johnson thank you
I came to Legend I think the very last
point was about 5.7.6 was that you were
the very last point Sorry through your
chair and 5.7.6 was about the uh nature
and development proposed off-site
impacts on nature conservation yeah
thank you
so do you want to respond to that or
should we take further comments thank
you I'll just try and respond to them as
as best as I can it may not be complete
but obviously it can always come back if
I if I've missed something out
um
nature views um Council Legend asked
about the uh with with you know if
essentially
is this a community use this is a
medical use how does that relate to the
floor space I think
and what can the floor space be used for
and Council again stated
um if it were for specifically medical
use then that would
be considered maybe I'm not saying more
favorably but there'd be a different
consideration to that if that's correct
here
um the the policy is quite General in a
sense when it talks about Community uses
it it it's not specific just to an
osteopath it says an osteopath it's a
type of community use
of a medical nature
this could be something it could be a
doctor's surgery it could be something
of any of those type of uses they would
similarly fall within that category of
use which would be
um supported by this policy so that's
that's the wireless explanation to that
so it's not just limiting it to a
particular type of
medical use in this sense which may be
an Osteopath
yeah it may not have carried the same
weight in as a doctor surgery but equate
Force within that same use class
so
officers have only assessed what's in
front of them
if this was any other use that that that
that was uh pertaining towards
um being consistent with the policy on
that basis it would be supported in the
same way yep
um
you talked about the rent and I do
appreciate that what officers are saying
that
in looking at the applicant's website
and looking at the advertisement the
rent
sort related to a 25 square meter area
it does not relate to the totality of
the floor space
on of this application in front of us so
they're raises some question marks in
terms of officers views in terms of how
robust does this assessment been
now
while
um
anyone can go on the website and look at
the application file look at all the
details the specific details in terms of
what's been submitted
in office's view is not satisfactory
um
when in the report it's mentioned as I
highlighted in my summary unspecified
dates
we effectively had an A4 sheet with two
um
printed entries on it showing floor
space and having a quick blurb of you
know what the what the proposed well
this is the area that is sought
um that has been advertised
um
in my experience
when a base with similar applications
you get a substantial report uh between
detail all the information about the
premises how the marketing has has gone
about it's normally carried out by
independent surveyors looking at this or
even reputable High Street surveyors to
corroborate and provide the necessary
evidence for this sorts of application
in our view
an A4 sheet with just two printed
entries is not sufficient evidence
now we're not necessarily saying that
the evidence can't be put in front of
officers but what's been put in front of
us is set is unsatisfactory
so that's that's that's the point there
I may well have missed another point
that you raised Council again so please
do remind me at a later point no thank
you very much indeed Mr Johnson thank
you chair
I think it was Johnson I think councilor
Jennings and then councilor spenceley
councilor Jennings
thank you chair
um I refer to 0.5.7.6
um where it regards nature
um walking past
the area in particular this evening on
my way home from work
I took a great interest in looking at
the nature surrounding that area we have
a road we have a car park we have a back
of a supermarket
I couldn't see any foreseeable signs of
Nature and the impact it would have on
that particular area
um I think the cars in the car park have
a more detrimental effect on the nature
of the environment rather than that
particular building
um next point is
5.4.1 listed building impact
I believe is my knowledge being a
maldonian that that part of the king's
head Center used to be a barn
pretty sure that what it is now
has had a greater impact on the listed
building side of things and the look of
the whole facility
than what it was a barn in disrepair
they're into my points thank you
uh thank you councilor Jennings do you
want to come back on that Mr Johnson yes
um thank you thank you chair uh really
just just a quick response
um the
5.7 around nature contributions uh sorry
nature conservation
but then as it goes on to 5.7.6 and
actually I think that's something that
Council again did mention as it's come
to my mind now it talks about Essex
codes for Rams
um
now firstly
um the application is not saying that
there is any impact
um from this proposal as such on nature
conservation
but what it's saying and where it uh
this is complies with policy
is that where there is
a use proposed that will result in
additional footfall within a Zone
um and this this is a Zone which
protects
um these special areas within Malden
um with additional foot four it means
that particularly of a tourist nature
there will be utilizing uh potentially
these special protected areas this is
this is zones that's come that supplied
across Essex
um so it
if an application has been supported in
that respect then one would need to be
paying a tariff that tariff is 157
pounds 36 as I recall it been amended
recently
it's it's it's pretty standard in
applications like this if for example
members were to be supporting this
application
as as part of
um the uh conditions or a unilateral
undertaking I would be suggesting that
um any permission be include a Rams
tariff that's that's pretty standard
um it's only there is a reason for
refusal on this application because one
has not been submitted with this
application but this is normally with
the agreement of the application
something that can be overcome
so that's in that respect
um
your other point was on
I think it was
5.4.1
and that might that one might have
slipped me could you throw again it was
five point
five point four point one listed
building impact oh yeah listed building
and the fact that that
um the report the report
doesn't well before categorically states
that there is no impact on the listed
building
thank you chairman okay thank you Miss
Johnson uh I think we'll go to council
Paula spenceley
thank you chair so um looking at page 16
5.2.8 and the second part of that
paragraph where it says however is part
of the application no supporting
information has been provided to
demonstrate that there is an identified
need for the provision proposed the
council has commissioned a visitor
accommodation study the initial results
of which support the provision of
additional holiday accommodation within
the district but mainly for hotel and
self-catering accommodation in the rural
area unlike the development of the
subject of the current application so a
couple of questions come to me from
looking at that first of all when was
this visitor accommodation study
commissioned
um and it says initial results
I'm not aware of those as a member I
don't know if anybody else is is aware
exactly what the results of that are
um but I I sat in here on a previous
planning meeting during the pre-election
periods and maybe the pre-election
period sent me slightly mad I'm not sure
but I do recall that there was another
application where we were looking at an
Airbnb and it seemed to be suggested
there that accommodation was very much
needed in the town center and and yet
here we're being told it's not needed in
the Town Center so I'm a little bit
confused about that and I would have
thought actually that a town center
location surely I'll be saying that
there isn't I mean I I can't think of
any reason why people wouldn't want to
stay in the Town Center so that seems a
little bit loose to me to be perfectly
honest the other thing is and I do
understand you're alluding to a doctor's
surgery Mr Johnson but let's be honest
we've got two Satellite surgeries in
haybridge and the problem is finding the
doctors not finding the surgeries so
um you know again I I knowing that
premise is I find that a little bit
tenuous I think we do you have to accept
as time moves on we would all like to
see bustling High streets full of retail
and these kinds of community Provisions
in reality the nature of our high
streets have changed and we do to a
certain extent have to accept that I
mean if I was walking up the High Street
only yesterday and noticing how many
buildings we now have vacant how many
premises so I'm you know being that I do
believe this would contribute towards
maintaining the center from what I've
heard
um
for the king's head Center you know
that's a concern to me but I would I
would like to understand exactly what
was behind this visitor accommodation
study and whether or not it's
specifically referenced that there was
no need for Town Center accommodation or
no desire for it thank you
thank you Kim suspensely
um Mr Johnson
thank you chairman um
I I can't actually give you the details
of what this study is myself that is not
something I
personally have looked at in a great
deal of details unfortunately the
officer is not here who wrote this
report to actually make that clear
distinction for you but I understand
um it's um
[Music]
it's a report within the last year or
two this is not an age document but I
don't know that I don't know the details
of it so I can't actually give you that
information to support your
um your further understanding of that
um
in terms of the in terms of the use
um I think the the overriding in fact
when we look at the reason for refusal
um
at section eight
although that comment that you
highlighted is stated within the report
the reason for refusal
um is that the proposal does not comply
with the policy because it's not been
demonstrated
that the existing business is not viable
and that effective marketing
has been undertaken
that's the essential reason for refusal
and that is really what members are
looking at here
I think that's fairly clear in itself
it's not the visitor study report
um while that's background information
to the information in front of you the
reason for refusal and I think that's
why I sort of labored on it in the
initial presentation was around the fact
that the information we're looking for
would normally expect of a particular
standard has not been submitted with
this and as I said previously had that
been the case there may have been a
different outcome I can't prejudge that
but the the information wasn't there for
us to be in that position to to to to to
come to a different view okay thank you
thank you Miss Johnson uh councilor Nick
spenceley please thank you chair
um so the context we're facing is
economic stagnation at best or recession
um and one of the bright spots on the
horizon is an upturn in tourism fueled
by
a lot of factors including the
popularity of Malden as a filming
location so so my understanding of S3
policy S3s is that
um and I may be misunderstanding it
because it's new to me there's a danger
that it will preserve facilities in
aspect awaiting businesses which will
not materialize
um how flexible is is that policy and
um
why are we not looking at molden Town
Center as a location for people who can
come here enjoy the town spend their
money pay entrance fees and and boost
our economy
okay
it's Johnson thank you chairman again
I'll probably be reiterating some of
what I said to um councilor Mrs
spencerley
um
the reason for refusal on this
application is based around E3
um yeah
um and the particular element in E3
which is about demonstrating and and
this application has been determined or
rather recommended for refusal because
it has not been demonstrated
um
I I I understand the argument you know
the changing nature of town centers Etc
buildings may be coincide Nation or not
but
the local plan is not
while there is an emphasis on trying to
stimulate
um economic growth and development as
soon as possible there is also a
long-term element to this as well in
terms of
um how buildings may be used in the
future
the range of users that that they can be
put to before we as officers can support
a change of use out of what the primary
or the existing use may be even if it's
within a similar use class too or a
similar consideration to your holiday
let's in your and your hotels there just
has to be this exercise to go through
and that's clearly within the plan
you know I mean the
our decision makers making premise is
the Primacy of the plan that's what we
go by and it's there for a specific
reason
um where that's been exhausted to our
satisfaction then we can consider
alternative use I mean this is a sort of
standard approach in planning and it's
not to say that the applicant as I've
said several times already cannot come
back with the information that that's
relevant
I mean I'm sure we can find an
application that can show you where you
can see some very substantial
information to make the point other than
as I've sort of stressed and I'm not
being flippant or just colloquially and
saying that but I I I need an A4 sheet
with a a a a where probably about a
third of it
comprises
um the two
um advertisement attempts
as part of the evidence base that has
been appropriately marketed that in my
view categorically is not is not
acceptable in our view thank you
chairman
I think Miss Johnson I'm uh cancer Jane
I'll pick you up later but there's a
couple of the people who've been waiting
to jump in so councilor shauncey
thank you chairman I just like to draw a
members attention to 5.7 actually the
whole of pipe of 5.7
um I I really think that a one bedroom
flat is not going to have
um an impact to the extent stated here
in 5.7
um on the um the natural environment I
mean if I thought it was going to I
would be the first person to say so as
other members
um will know
um but I really think this is an
Overkill here a one bedroom flat is not
going to have that effect
I think you can Sean C do you want to
come back or shall we yeah I just need
to make that that point
um the
the contribution towards Rams is Rams
it's a tariff
um and I and I I I have to I strongly
state that this is a Essex wide
um
process this is not just a modern
process Malden have bought into that
process because by government
legislation our protected areas of
Blackwater Etc they need to be protected
um the the means of protecting that is
through acquiring funds where there's a
potential for additional football within
the district
uh you know I mean there's been housing
schemes which have been refused
on just maybe just that point because
there is not the contribution towards
the Tariff towards
um those fundings and the monitoring
that that goes with it so I I would just
raise my concern if the re the the need
for the Rams tariff on any application
of which it needs to be applied is
dismissed thank you chairman uh thank
you Ms Johnson
um I councilor stilts uh and then I'll
come back to council Jennings and then
I'll pick up councilor Burwood Council
Stills thank you Mr chairman
um first of all the
um study was actually done this year the
tourism study it hasn't actually been
accepted yet
so that is one thing and it does state
that there is a general shortage in uh
accommodation for tourism if I'm right
tourism is an industry
and if you look at what our town center
is Our Town Center downstairs is all
shops
upstairs it's accommodation tourist
accommodation and housing
if you look at 5.2.5 it says where
possible there is good connections with
other tourist destinations the green
infrastructure Network and local
Services preferably by walking cycling
or other sustainable modes of Transport
what better place can you get than a
town center they can walk to the
restaurants they can walk to the moot
Hall they can walk to tourist
attractions they can get on buses and go
to other places
I propose Mr chairman that we accept
this
recommend that we accept this proposal
or this application
thank you
thank you cancer stilts I I've there's a
couple of other comments so before I do
anything with that
proposal can I just take oh back to Camp
back to counselor Jennings and then
councilor burwood's thank you thank you
chair um just a comment for Mr Johnson
correct me if I'm wrong that policy E5
in our own ldp states that the council
will support developments which
contribute positively to the growth of
local tourism in a sustainable Manner
and realize opportunities that arise
from The District's landscaped Heritage
and built environment the king's head
has a huge amount of Heritage in the
town and uh many modernians will
remember the king's head way back when
um including some of my own members of
my family so
um yeah I'm pretty sure that our own ldp
supports this application
uh oh I'll just take these comments and
because I think you'll just be repeating
you'll be you're repeating yourself
councilor Burwood and then I'll take
counselor like and having looked at the
comments on here it seems to me that
these 15 pages say that this is being
recommended for refusal because one
piece of paperwork hasn't been completed
and yes there's lots of stuff in there
about conservation and all those other
sorts of things what concerns me is that
if we if we if we pass this with this
paperwork not being completed
satisfactory are we setting a precedent
and that's the only only point I want to
make on that is we we may well set a
precedent for any future applications in
in in with from other applicants in
future to to
get around potentially filling in
information that is vital to make for us
to make an informed decision
thank you
Mr Johnson do you want to come back on
that particular point Thank You chairman
um but I do appreciate counselor for
making the very point I think I've been
stressing here
um and again as you said I've been
repeating myself to draw back to the
reasons for refusal the reason for
refuel is not against the use per se the
reason for the future is against the
process the process is embedded within
the policy this is the concern and
element
um and I think the council has
eloquently stated that
um that there could well be a precedent
for other applicants following the same
process and drawing on the example of
committees where
um uh processes within the UDP
UDP with it within our ldp has been
ineffectively sidestepped
um
the reason for refusal is not against
the use it just says that the proposal
cannot be supported
because it's failed to comply with or it
hasn't demonstrated that's the reason
for refusal and a member should not lose
sight of that as I've said before and
examples are drawn with another similar
case earlier on this year where we have
supported an application for a holiday
lit use so we're not averse of that in
fact I was at that very committee and
I'm sure as a character member making
very strong Arguments for that
application
um but this is a different context here
it's almost as again don't want to be
you know speaking to colloquially but
it's almost like it was
yeah I don't want to say half-baked yeah
but it did it did leave a lot to be
desired for my professional point of
view having dealt with similar changes
of uses but you always get change of use
application that's contrary to policies
but you have to jump through the Hoops
to get it once that's been done the
Integrity of the local plan is
maintained
um and if they come back with the same
Proposal with the relevant evidence it
can be submitted
considered differently thank you
chairman thank you Miss Johnson uh
councilor Lagan if I made chair could I
just give away to council lay who hasn't
spoken yet and then speak after thank
you
and select thank you chair uh yes as
this is in the center of the mo of
Malden it's very important to me and
certainly to the residents about what
happens with the use of the properties
within the central area of the town and
obviously to see the growth in tourism
and to change the use here is mentioned
there's quite a lot of information
coming up at us from different
directions I'm very concerned that the
survey hasn't been shared and shows that
there is a need for Rural
accommodation yet the town does not need
it it does need it it's a very important
part of the district it's a hub it
people come here to do that to come to
the town and value what's here
um it's a new business from my
understanding it's a new business as
well so some of the statements and
numbers for a new business will be not
proven track record or income or things
that can be actually put onto paperwork
but we things that will be projected for
that type of income so they may change
in what they're doing so this is I
fully support new businesses to the town
definitely football was mentioned as
well sorry there's just a couple of
things there would be football to an
osteopath as it would be perhaps more
than to a tourist destination as a
rental with different sets of people so
I think there are many criteria for us
to weigh here but I don't see how this
is proven through I appreciate the
report and the detail but there are some
serious questions about the reasons for
a refusal thank you thank you uh do you
want to come back Council agent yeah
just basically I've been listening to
the debate which I think is very strong
debate and also the views um of Mr
Johnson who is a professional planner at
the end of the day and I know there's a
proposal on the table by councilor
Stills but I'd actually put a proposal
out that we defer this
um especially
um to to look for more information and
to meet the so we've maintain the
Integrity of the local plan and and also
there's Parts in it that I think if if
we were minded on another report which
we would have to look at the the merits
of that in 5.6.4 there's even a
statement there that a condition could
be imposing planned permission would be
granted you're kind of bicycle store so
we could do a bicycle store which is I
think was something we need the Rams
contributions we can get all of the
Ducks lined up and then for make a fully
informed decision in compliance with the
plan so that's a proposal thank you
oops that's a counter proposal well just
before we go that's uh so we've got two
proposals sitting on them
I know well neither have been saying
I've got no indeed I've got two more
let's take two more comments and then
we'll we'll sort out these proposals uh
so uh councilor Spence Lee paulus
Bensley and then and then back to you
cancer stilts I was going to propose
deferral so I'll second councilor
lagan's proposal
okay uh
uh so that's the first proposal that's
been proposed and seconded
uh but we do have to deal with the first
proposal first
it hasn't been seconded but it has been
proposed do you wish to withdraw that
proposal or do we want I I would
actually be your first change my
proposal slightly to say that
my proposal to accept this stands but
that the Rams is paid
and more information is brought forward
I think that deferring it is not going
to do anything I think we should look at
what we've got on the table and my
proposal would be to accept this but the
Rams is paid subject to conditions and
the condition your that particular
condition being that the ram is paid
yeah but no other condition you're well
if we have any other conditions we have
to vote on those conditions separately
right okay so we okay so I think that's
the first that is the first proposal do
we have a sector for that particular
proposal then we'll decide on so
councilor Jennings is
uh seconding that particular ProStar
first proposal is that we accept this
given the condition that the Rams
payment is made and that has been
seconded by councilor Jennings so on
fact proposal can we vote please
councils those in favor of that proposal
yeah that's three four and against
yeah
five against okay so that has not passed
so we go on to the second proposal from
councilor Lagan which is
uh that this is deferred uh to a point
where we've got some more information
and as Council again put it the Ducks
are lined up and that I believe was
seconded by councilor spencely
can I ask a quick question Mr Johnson is
this a Time critical
um application so by deferring it would
we incur expenses
thank you chairman uh no we wouldn't
incur expenses
okay so we have a proposal then that we
defer
um from Council again and secondly by
councilor Paula spensely so can I have a
vote in favor of that proposal please
six and against
three against any abstentions
no
thanks chairman just some further
Clarity on the on the deferral
so that is to seek
um the well some clarity on some element
in the report especially around the
visitor study Etc
but also some clarity around the
marketing I'm not quite sure about that
element yeah through your chair I think
what you said Mr Johnson which is very
apt I think we we looked at some more
clarity about the marketing and the
property
um getting conditions
imposed about bicycle stores looking
making sure we've got the Rams
um payment made and any other applicable
um
requirements through a change of use
application like this are are met if
that's I mean thank you chairman I mean
this is largely also for the purposes of
the of the applicant and their Regent to
understand what we'd be seeking for in
this deferral period
uh can counselors Wednesday it was a
just going to say exactly that are
particularly around the marketing
information that officers in their
professional opinion would
see that an opportunity for the
applicants to provide that to show that
it would in fact be compliant with the
ldp because the marketing evidence was
there I think would it is you know
because what what was being said by the
applicant by the agent indicated that
they have more evidence so it would be
really to differ for that reason as well
as the others given by councilor Lagann
thank you
uh thank you cancer spensely I think
that that concludes that is there
anything further Mr Johnson in terms of
clarification in relation to deferral
which would help the applicant or
do you feel that it is sufficiently
clear for them to go away and do what's
needed
I I think it's sufficiently clear chair
chairman thank you
we move on to item six uh items of
business uh that just the chairman
decides it's urgent there are none
and therefore I close the meeting at 8
22. thank you very much